My name is chrysostom flower
work that is being represented here
in this place at this time I think
that regardless of the connection
that you have directly with me is
interpret the pain of the Mexican people
in general
ah
I am the mother of three young people from the age of
these young people my family lives in equals
warrior live in the center of the
shootings and the daily massacres there
on the part of our government the
repression are now used to
speak in code not to express what
feel not to walk the streets to not
go out at night to keep the
closed doors I think it's not fair what
what is happening in our country and it is not
just to what this government is
doing to his Mexican people
for us the day of the dead is
just remember the people that
physically they are no longer with us
but that his spiritual presence continues
connected with us are the people
that they give us
the strength to keep going the force
that they give us to continue struggles like
what these young people have undertaken
your rights as students for your
rights to be educated for their rights to
educate the people to new
generations
I believe that the whole country at this time
is afraid of what may happen to
his family unfortunately in mexico
from the government of the president felipe
Calderón when he declared war on
drug trafficking to date that we are
in 2014 there are approximately
30,000 missing what we
we are seeing in equals when the
local government murders 6 students and
11 and kidnaps 43 students and
is trying to deliver to parents
from these boys to their children
we see that there are pits and more graves and more
fosas mexico is a complete pit
I think young people are not well
they are no longer alive my heart tells me that
they are no longer alive but as people who
we are like human beings that we are
We need to see their bodies
when I spoke with the lord actions